The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
YEN-JIE LEE: So welcome
back, everybody.
This is the final
exam checklist.
For the single
oscillator, we need
to make sure that you
know how to write down
the Equation of Motion.
We have discussed about damped,
under-damped, critically
damped, and over-damped.
We did that.
Oscillators, and we have
tried to drive oscillators.
We observed transient behavior
in steady state solution.
Resonance, right, so which
we actually demonstrated that
by breaking the glass.
And then we moved on and tried
to couple multiple objects
together.
And that brings us to
the coupled system.
What are the normal modes?
And how to actually
solve M minus 1 K
matrix, the eigenvalue problem.
What is actually the full
solution for the description
of coupled systems.
And can we actually
drive the coupled system,
and we found out we can.
So the system would
respond as well
similar to what we have seen
in the single oscillator case.
We see resonance as well.
We can excite one
of the normal modes
by driving the coupled system.
Then we put more and more
objects until at some point,
we have infinite number
of coupled objects.
What is actually the
solution of refraction
and the transmission--
refraction and the
translation symmetric system.
That is actually the
discussion of symmetry.
We go to the continuum
then, and we actually
found wave and wave equations.
So we found that finally,
we made the phase transition
from single object
vibration to waves,
and that is actually
an achievement
we have done in 8.03.
We have discussed about
different systems,
massive string, massive
spring, sound wave,
electromagnetic
waves, and we have
discussed a progressive
wave and standing waves.
For the bound system, we
have also normal modes.
We discussed about
how to actually do
Fourier decomposition,
and what is actually
the physical meaning of
Fourier decomposition in 8.03.
For the infinite system, we also
learned about Fourier transform
and uncertainty principles.
And we learned to apply
boundary conditions
so that we constrain
the possible wavelengths
of the normal modes.
Therefore, we also
learned about how
to put a system all together.
Finally, how to determine
the dispersion relation,
which is omega as a function
of K, the wave number.
Until now, we discussed
idealized systems,
and we also moved on to
discuss dispersive medium.
We have learned some more,
even more about dispersion
relation for the dispersive
medium and signal transmission,
how to send signal through
a highly dispersive medium.
The solution we
were proposing is
to use an amplitude
modulation radio and also
the pattern of dispersion.
The group velocity and phase
velocity, we covered that.
As I mentioned before,
the uncertainty principle.
A 2D/3D system.
We have bound
system, which we have
normal modes for two-dimensional
and three-dimensional systems,
as well.
Because we're all
over the place,
so just make sure that you
know how to actually dewrap
all those standing waves
for different dimensions
of systems.
We showed and approved
geometrical optics,
which essentially is the
direct consequence of waves.
Wave function, a continuation of
the wave function and boundary
condition.
We learned about the refraction
rule and also Snell's law.
We talked about polarized waves,
linear, circularly polarized,
elliptically polarized,
and the polarizer
and quarter-wave plate.
At the end of the
discussion of 2D/3D systems,
we discussed about how to
generate electromagnetic waves
by accelerated charge.
Finally, we went on and
talked about how those EM
waves propagate in dielectrics
and again, boundary conditions,
which leads to interesting
phenomena, which belongs only
to electromagnetic waves.
For example, Brewster's angle.
So the refraction amplitude--
refraction-- the
wave amplitude is
governed by the property of the
electromagnetic waves, which
is coming from the
laws which governs
electromagnetic waves, which is
Maxwell's equations in matter.
We were trying to also
manipulate those waves
by adding them
together, and we see
constructive and destructive
interference and diffraction
phenomena.
Then we connect that
to quantum mechanics
by showing you a single electron
interference experiment.
That connects us
to the beginning
of the quantum mechanics, which
is the probability waves, which
behave very different from other
waves we have been discussing.
But you are going to
learn a lot more in 8.04.
OK, so don't worry.
All right.
So that is the checklist.
You can see that I can
write it in two pages,
so it's not that bad, probably.
I hope that there was nothing
really sounds like new to you
by now.
If you find anything is new,
you have to review that part.
That means you missed a class.
All right.
So what I'm going to do now is
to go through all the material
faster than the speed of light.
All right.
So that you will get nauseated.
No, you are going to get
a list of the topics.
You just have to feel it.
If you feel good, like when
you are having a cupcake,
right, then you are
good for the final.
If you don't feel good, what
is Professor Lee talking about?
He's talking about nonsense now.
Then you are in trouble, and
you have to review that part.
All right?
OK.
So that's what we'll do.
So let's start.
All right.
Why 8.03?
We started a discussion--
welcome, We started
a discussion of 8.03
and it's vibrations and wave
systems, is name of this, 8.03.
And the motivation
is really simple,
because we cannot even recognize
the universe without using
waves and vibration.
You cannot see me, and
you cannot hear anything,
and you cannot feel
the vibrations--
sorry, the rotation of a
black hole by your body
anymore, then it's
not very cool.
Therefore, we study 8.03 to
understand the basic ideas
about waves and vibrations.
And we found that
waves and vibrations
are interesting phenomena.
Waves are connected
to vibrations.
Because if you look
at only, for example,
a single object on
these waves, you
see that it is actually a single
object which is oscillating
up and down,
oscillating up and down,
and this is your vibration.
So there's a close connection
between single particle
vibration and the waves.
And that is the first
thing that you learned.
Therefore, we need to first
understand the evolution
of a single particle system.
And we make use of
this opportunity
to start the discussion
of scientific matter.
So using this
opportunity, basically,
what we have been doing for the
whole class is the following.
So the first step is
always to translate
the physical
situation which we are
interested into
mathematics, right?
Because mathematics is the only
language which we know which
describes the nature.
If you come out
with a new language,
and that is going to be a
super duper breakthrough,
it cannot be estimated
by Nobel Prize.
But the problem
we are facing now
is that this is the only
language we know which works.
Therefore, we really
follow this recipe,
which is similar to many,
many other physics classes.
And we have a
physical situation,
we use laws of nature
or models, and we
have a mathematical
description, which
is the Equation of Motion.
And this is actually
the hardest part,
because you need to first define
a coordinate system so that we
can express everything in
a system in that system,
then you can make use of the
physical laws you have learned
from the previous 8.01
and 8.02 to write down
the Equation of Motion.
And most of the mistakes,
and also most of the problems
or difficulties you are
facing is always in this step.
Then we can solve the Equation
of Motion, which is, strictly
speaking, not my problem.
It's the math
department's problem.
Yeah, that's their problem.
Then we solve the
Equation of Motion,
and you will be
given the formula.
Then we use initial conditions
and then make predictions.
And then we would
like to compare that
to experimental results.
And that is the
general thing which
we have been doing for physics.
So let's take a look
at those examples.
Those are examples of
simple harmonics motions.
And you can see that
these, all these systems
have one object,
which is oscillating.
And you can see that
their Equations of Motion
are really similar
to each other.
It's theta double dot plus
omega, zero squared, theta
equal to zero for those
idealized simple harmonic
motions.
And we learned that the
solution of those equations
are the same, which
is a cosine function.
Then we went ahead and added
more craziness to the system.
So basically, what
we tried to do
is to add a drag
force into the game.
And we were wondering if this
more realistic description can
match with experimental data.
So this is the
Equation of Motion,
and the additional turn
is the one in the middle,
the gamma theta dot turn.
And after entering these
turns, not only is this
an interesting model to
describe the physical system we
are talking about, but
the mathematical solution
is far more richer than
what we talked about
in the single harmonic
oscillator case.
Basically, you see that a
general solution depends
on the size of the gamma
compared to omega dot zero,
which is the oscillation--
the natural frequency
of the system.
OK.
And then you can see there are
three distinct different kinds
of solutions.
They have different
mathematical forms.
And we call them
under damped solution,
critically damped solution,
and over damped solution.
So those equations
will be given to you.
And the excitement
is the following.
So you can see that
those solutions,
if you plot the solution
as a function of time,
they look completely different
as a function of time.
So in the case of no damping,
the amplitude is actually
the constant, it's not actually
reducing as a function of time.
But when the damped
system, the damping
is turned on, then in the
under damped situation,
you can see that they end up
reducing as a function of time.
And if you have
too much damping,
you put the whole oscillator
into some liquid, for example,
and you see that
oscillator disappear.
The cool thing is the following.
The excitement
from-- as a physicist
is that all of those crazy
mathematical solutions
actually match with
experimental results.
Wow.
That is really cool.
Because there is nobody
saying that these should match
and how, naturally, I
should learn that OK,
when should I change the
behavior of the system.
So this is really a miracle that
this complicated mathematical
description is useful and
that it is super useful
to describe the nature.
Once we have learned that, we
can now add a driving force
into ligand.
From the equation
here, we can see
that there is a natural
frequency, omega dot zero,
of this system, and there
is a drag force turn, which
is actually to quantify
how much drag we have,
we have a gamma there.
We are driving it at a
driving frequency omega t.
So what we have
learned from here
is that if you are driving this
system, you are-- for example,
I am shaking that
student, shaking you.
OK, in the beginning, this
student is going to resist.
No, don't shake me.
Come on.
But at some point, he
knows that Professor Lee
is really determined.
Therefore, he is going to be
shaked at the frequency I like.
OK.
So that is actually
what is happening here.
This is so-called
transient behavior.
So in the beginning, the
system doesn't like it.
So this is making use of
the superposition principle.
So you can solve that
homogeneous solution, which
is on the right-hand side.
It depends on the
physical situation
you are talking about.
You choose the corresponding
homogeneous solution.
And lamba and psi is the driving
force from E and G, right,
and that is going to win at
the end of the experiment,
because I'm going
to shake it forever,
until the end of the universe.
So you can see that at the
end, you-- what is left over
is really the steady
state solution.
And it has this structure,
A omega d, depends on omega.
And you get resonance behavior.
Don't forget to review that.
So you have a delay
in phase because when
I shake the student, the student
needs some time to respond.
Therefore, the delta is non-zero
if the student is damped.
All right.
So now we have learned all the
secrets about a single object
system.
Then we can now go ahead and
study coupled oscillators.
There are a few
examples here, which
is coupled pendulums or
coupled spring-mass systems.
And we found that a
very useful description
of this kind of
system is to make
use of the matrix language.
So originally, if you have
n objects in a system,
you have n Equations of Motion,
and that looks horrible.
But what is done in 8.03 is
that we introduce a notation
with a matrix.
Basically, if you write
everything in terms of matrix,
then it looks really
friendly, and it looks really
like a single oscillator.
OK?
Although solving this
equation is still
a little bit more work.
And basically, you can see
that from this example,
we can actually derive
M minus 1 K matrix,
and the whole
equation won't be--
the Equation of Motion
problem solving problem
becomes an M minus 1 K
matrix eigenvalue problem.
What is an M minus 1 K matrix?
This is describing how each
component in the system
interacts with each other.
Once we have this, we can
solve the eigenvalue problem,
and we are going to
be able to figure out
the normal modes
of those systems.
So what is a normal mode?
Normal modes is
a situation where
all the components in the
system are oscillating
at the same frequency and they
are also at the same phase.
So that is the definition
of normal mode.
And those are what is
used in a deviation,
also, which leads us to
the eigenvalue problem.
We define Z equal to X
1 H or I omega t plus 5.
Everybody is oscillating at
omega and also at phase 5,
right?
So that is what we
actually learned.
And what is actually
the physical meaning
of those normal modes?
So if we plot the locus
of the two coupled
pendulum problem, what
we see is the following.
So basically, you will
see that the locus looks
like really complicated
as a function of time
if you plot X1 X2 versus time.
But if we rotate
this system a bit,
then we find that there's a
really interesting projection,
which is the
principal coordinate.
You see that all those
crazy strange phenomena
we see with coupled
systems are just illusions.
Actually, you can
understand then
by really using the
right projection.
To one-- to the right
coordinate system.
Then you will see that actually
the system is doing still
simple harmonic motion.
So that is actually
the core thing
which we learned
from coupled systems.
So we learned about how to
solve the coupled system,
and we also learned about
going to an infinite number
of coupled systems.
So then this is an example here.
So for example, I can
have pendulum and springs,
and we connect
them all together,
and I need to hire many, many
students so that they plays it,
plays until it fills
up the whole universe.
So this is the idea
of an infinite system.
You can see that
that means my M minus
1 K matrix is going
to be an infinite
times infinite long matrix.
It's two dimensional.
And the A is infinitely long.
And that sounds really scary.
And in general, we don't know
how to deal with this, really.
And it can be as arbitrarily
crazy as you can imagine.
What we discuss 8.03
is a special case.
Basically, we are
discussing about systems
which are having a spatial
kind of symmetry, which
is translation symmetry, as you
can see from all those figures.
And you can see that
all those figures will
have to all have the same normal
modes because of this base
translation symmetry.
What we discussed about is that
we introduce an S matrix, which
is used to describe
the kind of symmetry
that this system satisfies.
And if we calculate the
commutator S and M minus 1 K
matrix, if this commutator
shows that the evaluate--
if you evaluate this
commutator and you get zero,
now it means they commute.
And the consequence is that the
S matrix and the S M minus 1 K
matrix will share the
same eigenvectors.
So you don't really need to
know how to derive this--
to arrive at this
conclusion, but it
is a very useful conclusion.
So that means instead of solving
M minus 1 K matrix eigenvalue
problem, I can now go ahead to
solve the S matrix eigenvalue
problem.
And usually, that's much easier.
So for the exam,
you need to know
how to write down S matrix.
You need to know how to solve
eigenvalue problems, including
M minus 1 K matrix
and the S matrix.
And then we can get to normal
mode frequency, omega squared,
and we can also solve the
corresponding normal modes.
And here is telling
you what would
be the solution for space
translation of the matrix
system.
And basically what
we will see is
that making use of the
S matrix should be--
brings you to the
conclusion that A,
j must be proportional to
exponential i, j, k, a,
where this A is the length scale
of this system, the distance
between all those little mass.
And the j is a label which
tells you which little mass
I am talking about.
And k is the--
some arbitrary constant.
But by now, you should have
the idea basically that's--
that's what?
That, essentially, is
the wave number, right?
So that is really cool.
So that's all
planned in advance.
And basically, you can see that
we can also write down the A, k
because we know that A, j will
be proportional to exponential
i, j, k, A, after solving
the eigenvalue problem for S
matrix.
Then we actually went one step
forward to make it continuous.
So basically, we made the space
between particles very, very
small.
And also, at the
same time, we make
sure that the string
doesn't become supermassive.
And we concluded that we
get some kind of equation
popping out from this exercise.
M minus 1 K matrix becomes minus
T over rho L partial square,
partial x squared.
You don't have to really
derive this for the exam,
but you would need to
know the conclusion
and that psi j becomes psi
as a function of x and t.
And the magical
function appeared,
which is the wave equation.
Oh my god, this is
the whole craziness
we have been dealing
with the whole 8.03.
This is actually
really remarkable
that we can come from
single object oscillation,
putting it all together,
making it continuous,
then this equation
really popped out.
And this equation really
describes multiple systems.
Then we went ahead to
actually discuss the property
of the wave equation.
It looks like this.
Basically, I replaced the t
over rho L by v, p squared.
By now, you know
the meaning of v,
p is actually the
phase velocity.
And we discussed two
kinds of solutions,
special kinds of solutions.
The first kind is normal modes.
The second one is
progressive wave solution,
or traveling wave
solution, whatever name
you want to call it.
Let's take a look at the normal
modes, what have we learned.
So if you have a bound system,
a bound continuous system,
the normal mode is your
distending waves for the wave
equation we discussed.
And basically, the
functional form
is A, m, sine, k, m, x plus
alpha, m and sine, omega, m, t
plus beta, m.
So what we actually learned
from the previous lecture
is the following.
So basically, you can
decide the k, m and alpha,
m by just boundary conditions.
So before you introduce
boundary conditions, which
are the conditions
allow you to describe
multiple nearby
systems consistently.
So that is the meaning
of boundary condition.
Before you introduce
that, k, m and alpha,
m are arbitrary numbers.
Whatever number
you choose is the--
can satisfy the wave equation.
But after you introduce
the boundary condition,
you figure that out from the
problem you are given, then k,
m and alpha, m cannot
be arbitrary anymore.
And they usually become
discrete numbers.
OK.
So that is what we learned
from the previous lectures.
And finally, we
also see that omega,
m is determined by the
property of the system,
by a so-called
dispersion relation.
In this case, it's linear,
it's proportional to k, m,
because we are talking
about non-dispersive medium
for the moment.
And we have this beta,
m, which is related
to the initial condition.
And the a, m, which
can be determined
by a Fourier decomposition.
So if you are not
familiar with this,
you have to really review how
to do Fourier decomposition.
I know most of did very
well on the midterm,
but maybe some of you
forgot how to determine a, m
and it will be
very, very important
to review that for the
preparation for the final.
Now the second set of
solutions is the following.
So you have progress--
progressing waves.
And the functional form
is really interesting.
So you can see this
can be written as F,
F is some arbitrary function,
x plus-minus v, p, t.
Basically that is that you're
describing a wave which
is traveling to the positive--
to a negative or positive
direction in the x direction.
Or you can actually
write it down
as G function k, x
plus-minus omega, t.
Actually, they all work
for wave equations.
Now we went ahead
and applied approach
which we learned from the
general solution of wave
equation to massive strings, and
we discussed about sound waves.
For the sound waves, it
will be important to review
what are the boundary
conditions for the displacement
of the molecules
in the sound wave,
compare that to the
pressure deviation
from the room pressure.
So I think it's
important to make sure
that you understand the
difference between these two,
what are the boundary conditions
and basically it should be
very similar to the solution--
the boundary condition
for the massive strings.
And we also talked about
electromagnetic waves.
And that is another topic which
you will really have to review.
Several things which are
especially interesting is that
an electric field cannot be
without a magnetic field.
They are always
together, no matter what.
So if you have trouble
with the electric field,
then there must be trouble
in the magnetic field.
And that is governed by
the Maxwell's equation.
Before we go into
the detail of those,
we also discussed about
dispersive medium.
So in the case of
dispersive medium,
we used a special
kind of example, which
is strings with stiffness.
So basically, what we
found is that if you
have a certain kind of wave
equation, like this one,
I am writing this one here.
Basically, if I add
the additional term
to describe the stiffness,
then what is going to happen
is that the dispersion
relation, when
I ask you to plot the dispersion
relation, you will be--
I am requesting you to find the
relation between omega and K.
And I'm going over
this in more detail
because I see so many similar
mistakes on the midterm.
So basically what I'm
asking is omega versus K.
And in the-- if we don't have
this turn, then basically,
you have a straight line.
Straight line means you have
a non-dispersive medium.
And if you add
this turn, you need
to know how to evaluate
the dispersion relation.
The quickest way to evaluate
the dispersion relation is
to just simply plug in
the progresssing wave
solution for the G function
or harmonic progressing
wave solution, find omega--
K, x plus-minus omega
t, into this equation,
then you will be able to figure
out the dispersion relation.
And what we figure
out is the following.
If we include
stiffness, then you
can see that the dispersion
relation is not a line anymore
and is actually
some kind of curve,
and the slope is
actually changing.
And there are dramatic
consequence from this thing.
That means if I have
a traveling wave
with different wavelengths,
that means the phase velocity v,
p equal to omega
over K is going to be
different for waves with
different frequencies,
or different wavelengths.
So that is how you
clear the problem.
Because if I have initially
produced a signal which
is a triangle and
I let it propagate,
what is going to happen
is that the slow component
will be lagging behind.
Those are the slow components.
And the fast components will
go ahead of the nominal speed.
So there will be a
spread of the signal.
Originally, maybe you have
some kind of a square wave,
and this thing will become
something which is actually
smeared out in space, and
then you lose the information.
And we are going to
talk about that later.
And we also learned
about group velocity.
So what is your group velocity?
Group velocity v,
p-- oh, sorry, v,
g is actually partial
omega, partial K,
which is the slope of
a tangential line here.
And where the phase
velocity is connecting
this point to that point,
and the slope of this line
is the phase velocity,
and the slope of the line
cutting through this
point, which is giving you
the group velocity.
And we actually learned
the definition of--
the consequence of
group velocity and phase
velocity by introducing
you a bit phenomena.
Basically, we add two waves with
similar wavelengths, or wave
numbers.
Basically, what we
see is the following.
So basically, you see
some behavior like this.
We see this-- the superposition
of these two waves
which produce a bit phenomena
can be understood by something
which is oscillating really
fast modulated by a much
slower more variating envelope.
Basically, you can actually
understand the bit phenomena
by actually identifying these
two interesting structures.
And the speed of all
those little peaks
is traveling at phase velocity.
And the speed of the
envelope is found
to be traveling
at group velocity.
So that is what we have learned.
And we can have group velocity
and the phase velocity
traveling in the same direction.
And we can also have a
negative group velocity.
So that is a technique which is
really, really very difficult.
And I'm still trying to
practice and make sure
they I can demo that in 8.03.
Basically, it's like
the whole system,
the whole detailed structure
moving in a positive direction.
But the body, or
say the envelope,
is actually moving in
the negative x direction.
So that is also possible.
And you can actually
construct a system which
has a negative group velocity.
So once we have
done that, we also
tried to understand further
the description of the solution
for the dispersive medium.
So basically, what we actually
went over during the class
is that OK, now, if
the f function f of t
is describing Yen-Jie's hand,
and I'm holding an infinitely
long string and I shake
it as a function of time,
and that essentially,
this motion,
is actually described
by this f function.
What we know is that this
oscillation, OK, I can do one,
but I won't, but all
kinds of f functions
can be described
as superpositions
of many, many, many waves with
different angular frequencies.
So that's a miracle
which we borrowed
from the math department again.
And you can see
that f function can
be written as the sum of
all kinds of different waves
with different
angular frequencies
with population c omega.
This is the weight which makes
that become the f function.
And we can figure
out the c omega
by doing a Fourier transform.
And finally, what will be the
resulting wave function, psi,
x, t, which is the
wave function generated
by the oscillation of my hand.
And those are governed by the
wave equation, which gives you
the relation between
omega and the k
can be returned in
that functional form.
So the good news is that with
the help of Fourier transform,
we can also describe
and predict what
is going to happen no matter
if this system is dispersive
or not dispersive
using this approach.
OK.
So that is really cool.
And you can of course can
do a cross-check just to--
assuring that this is a
non-dispersive medium.
And you are also
going to get back
to what you should
expect the solution
to non-dispersive medium
for the psi, x, t.
So that is one thing which
is really remarkable.
And I think what
is needed to know
is not a deviation of
all those formulas,
but how the plotting and
the derived c omega by using
the formula you are given
and how to then put together
all the solutions and it
becomes the resulting solution
for the psi, x,
t, which is really
the solution we really care.
So for that, you need to know
how to do the integration.
You need to know how to derive
the dispersion relation.
Then one thing left over
is to put the problem
into that equation, which is
also given to you in a formula.
And we will not ask
you to do a very, very
complicated integration
for sure on the final.
So what is the consequence?
Basically, one thing which
is interesting to know
is that if you have a wave
in a coordinate space, which
is really widely spread out, and
you can do a Fourier transform
to get the wave population
in the frequency space, what
we find is that when this
wave is really, really
wide in the space,
then what we find
is that the wave population
in the frequency space
is very narrow by using
a Fourier transform.
And that just gives you the
result. And on the other hand,
if you have a really--
a very narrow pulse in
the coordinate space,
for example, I do this-- shwhew
--very, very-- really quickly.
I create a very narrow pulse.
And then what is
actually happening
is that I will have to use a
very wide range of frequency
space to describe this
very narrow pulse.
So that leads to--
direct consequences of that
is uncertainty principle.
And this is closely connected
to the uncertainty principle
we talk about in
quantum mechanics.
Delta, p times delta, x greater
or equal to h bar over 2.
All right.
So we have done with the
one-dimensional case.
And we also talked
about a two-dimensional
and a three-dimensional case.
And this is the example of
two-dimensional membranes,
and they actually are
constrained so that
their boundary condition at--
the boundary is equal--
no, the wave function
is equal to zero.
And you can identify
all those normal modes.
And we went ahead also to talk
about geometrical optics laws.
Basically, how we derive
that is to have a plane wave.
First, you have a
plane wave propagating
toward the boundary of
two different mediums,
and we were wondering well,
what is the refracted wave
and the transmitting wave.
By using the-- by making
sure just one point, which
is that the membranes
don't break,
the wave function is
continuous at this boundary.
That's the only
assumption which you use.
We went through the mathematics,
which you don't really
need to remember all of them.
But you really need to
remember the consequence.
The consequence
is the following.
Basically, what we see is that
if you have incident plane
wave with incident
angle theta 1,
the refractive wave will be
having an angle of theta 1
as well.
So that's the first law of
refraction, refraction law.
And then the second
one which we learned
is that the
transmitting wave will
satisfy Snell's law, n, 1,
sine, theta, 1 equal to n, 2,
sine, theta, 2.
And that is very interesting
because this, Snell's law
has also nothing to do
with Maxwell's equation.
You see?
Right?
That's actually what
you can learn from here.
We usually use
electromagnetic waves
to demonstrate Snell's law.
But from 8.03, we learned
that it has nothing
to do with Maxwell's equation.
It applies to all kinds of
different systems, which
you can--
which can be described
by wave functions.
So that is actually the
very important consequence.
But on the other hand, as
we all discussed later,
the relative amplitude of the
incident wave, refracted wave,
and transmitting wave,
the relative amplitude
is governed by
Maxwell's equation.
So I would like to make
that really crystal clear.
So the relative
amplitude is governed
by really the
physical laws, which
actually governs the propagation
of those plane waves.
OK.
So I think we can take a five
minute break to have some air.
And of course, you can-- you
are welcome to continue to use
all this juice and coffee.
And coming back at 38.
OK.
So welcome back,
everybody, from the break.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
YEN-JIE LEE: So we are going
to continue the discussion.
We have learned about
the two important laws
for the geometrical optics.
And we also went ahead to
discuss the polarization that's
solved in greater detail.
So for example, we can have
linear depolarized wave.
So basically, the wave is
essentially moving up and down,
up and down.
But the direction of
the background field
doesn't change.
It's always, for
example, initially,
if it's in x direction, then
it is x direction forever.
And in that case, I call
it linearly polarized.
Of course, I can
also have the case
that I can have a
superposition of two waves.
One is having the electric
field in the x direction.
And the other one is
in the y direction.
And they are off by
a phase of pi over 2.
If that happens,
then basically, you
will see that it produces
something really interesting.
That direction of
the electric field
is going to be rotating
as a function of time--
as a function of the
space these waves travel.
And we call it circularly
polarized waves.
And we can also have
elliptically polarized wave.
Then we learned about how
to do a filtering, which
is the polarizer.
So suppose I have a
perfect conductor here,
where I have the easy
axis, which is described
by the green arrow there.
And you can see
that easy axis means
that if you have electric field
parallel to the easy axis,
and then since that's the
easy axis, so it is supposed
to be easy, therefore, this
electric field is going to be
passing through the polarizer.
On the other hand,
if the electric field
is perpendicular to the
direction of the easy axis,
that means it's taking
the perfect conductor
in the hard way.
Therefore, when
it pass through--
when it is trying
to pass through
with the perfect conductor, the
electrons in those conductors
are going to be working like
crazy to deflect this wave when
the direction of
the electric field
is perpendicular to the
direction of the easy axis.
So that is how this works.
For example, in
the first example,
you can see that
in this case, you
have an easy axis which is
perpendicular to the direction
of the electric field,
which is the red field,
then this wave
actually got refracted.
There will be no transmission--
sorry, no electromagnetic field
passing the perfect conductor.
And on the other hand, if you
have another perfect conductor,
in which you have
easy axis which
is parallel to the electric
field, then you can--
you will see that it will pass
through the perfect conductor.
So that is the polarizer.
And also, we discussed
about quarter-weight plate,
which I would suggest you to
have a review about the concept
which we have learned
about polarizer
and quarter-wave plate so
that you make sure that you
understand how to calculate the
electric field after passing
through a polarizer
and quarter-wave plate
and how the secondary, or the
elliptically depolarized waves
are created using all those
wave plates, et cetera.
All right.
So the next thing which we
discussed during the class
is how do we produce
electromagnetic waves.
I think by now, you should
know that a stationary charge
doesn't produce
electromagnetic waves.
Even a moving charge
at constant speed
doesn't create
electromagnetic waves.
So how do we create an
electromagnetic wave
which propagates to the
edge of the universe?
That is-- the trick is to
create a kink in the fuel line.
So you have to
accelerate and stop it.
Accelerate and then try to
actually stop the acceleration.
So then you can create a kink.
And this kink is going to
be propagating out of the--
as a function of time.
And this kink is creating
the so-called radiation
from this accelerated charge.
So you don't really need to
remember all the deviations,
but you really need to
know the conclusion.
So what is the conclusion
is the following.
The radiated electric
field is equal to minus--
very important that there's
a minus sign in front
of it, which is a common
mistake to drop it, and the q
is the charge of
the oscillating--
the accelerated charge,
proportional to the charge.
If the particle is more charged,
then you have more radiation.
Aperp is the acceleration
projected to, which is--
the perpendicular projection
of the acceleration
of the particle with respect
to the direction of propagation
is so-called the Aperp.
And only the perpendicular
direction acceleration counts.
The one which is parallel to
the direction of propagation
doesn't really count, as you
can see from this equation.
And the t prime what
is t prime? t prime
is t minus r divided by c.
So t prime is the retarded
time, so that is telling you
that it takes some time
for the information
to propagate from
the origin, which
is the position of the moving
charge to the observer, which
is r, this distance, away
from the moving charge.
So the information takes
some time to propagate,
and you cannot know what is
really happening, for example,
100 light years away from Earth.
You have no idea about
what is happening.
Maybe a black hole
is created there
and is going to suck
everybody up in a few years.
But nobody knows, and we don't
care because we cannot control
it.
All right so that
is very important.
And also very important
to know the magnetic
field must be there.
You can see the relation
between magnetic field
and the electric field.
And the Poynting vector
is also its joint field.
And when we went ahead,
given all the knowledge
we have learned, we
discussed about how
to take very beautiful photos
using a polarizer filter.
And we discussed about how to
filter out the scattered light
from the sun.
And it would be
nice to figure out
why this is the case, how these
polarizer lines, scatter lines
are created.
It's purely geometrical.
And also, we discussed
about Brewster's angle
and also how it leads to the
explanation of the filtering
of the light, the refracted
light from the, for example,
window of a car
or from the water.
And this is the
demonstration of--
the summary of Brewster's angle.
So somebody reminded me that
the amplitude should be given.
So I think, this is
the amplitude formula
for Brewster's angle
will be given to you.
If not, it's asked
in the final exam.
So don't be worried
about it, and you don't
have to remember this formula.
And I'm not going to ask
you to derive that just
in such a short time, the
three hours in the final exam.
But what is very important is to
know how this Brewster's angle,
why there's no refracted
light polarizing in a way
that the polarization
should be--
why the refracted light
is polarized, for example.
And also why the transmitting
wave is slightly polarized.
And I think the conclusions
you need to remember,
and you need to know how to
calculate the angle, at least.
Because for this
purely polarized light
to be produced in
a refracted light,
you need to have normal
angle between the direction
of the refracted light
and the direction
of the transmitted light.
And that, you should
be able to remember.
And you should be able to
derive that also from your mind
as well, because that means the
direction of the oscillation
of the molecule at
the boundary will
be in the direction
of propagation
of the refracted wave.
Therefore, that cannot be the
solution to the progressing
electromagnetic wave.
Therefore, the refracted
waves are polarized.
So if you follow
this logic, then you
don't really need to
memorize all those formulas.
All right.
So finally, in the last
part of the course,
we focused on the superposition
of many, many electromagnetic
waves so you can produce
constructive interference.
Or that means all those
waves are in phase.
And you can have
destructive interference
when they are out of phase.
And that is a very
important topic,
so you should review that for
the preparation of the final.
And you can see that there are
three concrete examples which
we used during the class.
A laser beam.
We talked about a
water ripple in a demo.
And we also studied how it
make use of this phenomena
to design a phased radar.
So to detect this unknown object
in the sky, what we really
need to have is
electromagnetic waves pointing
to a specific direction.
And that can be achieved by
using multi-slit interference.
And this is the property of the
two-slit interference pattern.
And you are going to
have many, many peaks.
They have equal height
for two-slit interference
If you ignore any effect
coming from diffraction.
So we've assume that the
slit is infinitely small.
The slit is super narrow.
And then we can ignore
the diffraction--
single-slit diffraction.
In fact, then all the peaks due
to this two-slit interference
will have the same height.
On the other hand, when
we start to increase
the number of slits, for
example, unequal to 3,
unequal to 4, unequal
to 5, unequal to 6,
as you can see that, the
structure of the intensity
as a function of delta, which
is the phase difference,
is actually changing.
And you can see that the general
structure is the following.
So if you have unequal
to 3, then basically,
you have 2 of adult, and
between them, you have 1 child.
And if you have
unequal to 6, then
basically, you have 2
adults and somehow there
are 4 children in
this collection.
So basically, that is what
we learned from the solution
of the multi-slit interference.
And in this way, we
can actually make
the width of the principal
maxima as narrow as you want.
So that is why
phased radar works.
And then we discussed
about diffraction.
So that is related, again, to
the explanation of laser beams.
And we discussed about
the design of a Star Trek
ship, the gun for the ship.
And we also talked
about resolution.
And what is actually happening
here is the following.
A single-slit
diffraction essentially
can be viewed as an infinite
number of source interference.
And you just need to integrate
over all the point-like sources
between the two walls.
And all of them are acting
like a spherical wave source.
So basically, for every point--
continuously, every point
between these two walls
are a point source
of spherical waves.
And that is Huygens' principle.
And we can see
that the structures
is-- of the intensity as
a function of position
is the following.
So basically, you have
a principal maxima,
which is a peak in the middle.
And at some angle,
basically, you
have destructive
interference such
that if you integrate
over all the contributions
from an infinite number
of sources in this window,
basically, you would
see that they completely
cancel each other.
So that is the origin of all
those deep structure minima.
And then, after the
minima, actually, you
will see another peak,
but the height of the peak
is suppressed by 1
over beta squared.
And it would be
good to review that.
And what is the consequence?
So if you shoot a
laser beam to the moon,
the size of the laser
beam will be very large.
After you learn 8.03, you know
that the size of the laser beam
is going to be very, very
large due to interference
between all the point-like
sources from the laser beam.
And finally, we can
put them all together.
So the single-slit
diffraction and
the multi-slit interference,
you can put them
all together, and basically,
what you get is the following.
So basically, you have a
multi-slit interference
pattern, which is showing there.
But now the intensity of
the multi-slit pattern
is modulated by the single-slit
diffraction pattern.
And of course, the full
formula will be given to you.
But on the other
hand, you are also
requested to know how
to calculate, just
to add the contribution
from multi-slit
together in case if we change
the amplitude of the incident
light or we change
the phase, like what
we did in the homework.
And I think that is
one important point,
and you should review that.
And if you are not sure about
how to proceed with that,
it would be good to review
Lecture 22, Lecture 23.
So finally, we talk
about the connection
to quantum mechanics.
Einstein already told us that
"I have said so many times,
God doesn't play
dice with the world."
But what we actually
find is that there
are two very interesting
things which we found.
The first thing is that if we
have a single photon source,
and basically, if
we don't play dice,
we cannot explain the
intensity of the--
after this single photon source
passes through two polarizers.
And what happens
is the following.
Basically, the result of
a single photon source
tells you that you
really need to play dice
so that you can get the
resulting polarized light
intensity.
And also, the second
pseudo-experiment
we discussed is that if you
have billiard balls, basically,
you have them pass through
the two-slit experiment, what
you are going to
get is two piles,
Gaussian-like distribution.
And if you have a single
electron source, what it does
is that it interferes
with itself.
An electron, a single electron,
can interfere with itself
and produce a
pattern which is very
similar to what we see in
the double-slit interference
pattern.
So that is really remarkable.
And also, we talked
about a single-slit--
single electron experiment.
That gives you also a
diffraction pattern.
We have to use the wave
function to describe
the position-- the probability
density of the position
of the electron on the screen.
And know this issue closely
connected to the uncertainty
principle, which we discussed
earlier, delta, p, delta,
x is greater than or
equal to h bar over 2.
So if you have a
very narrow window,
that means you have
very similar delta x,
so you have very,
very good confidence
about the location
of the electron.
And then the momentum
is in the x--
in the momentum in
the x direction,
you have large uncertainty,
according to this equation.
And that can be seen from this
single-slit diffraction pattern
and it is closely connected to
what we have learned before.
So where is this-- how
to actually describe
what this is really
the dispersion
relation of the
probability density wave
is actually coming from
Schrodinger's Equation.
And this is given here.
We briefly talked about that.
And the consequence
is the following.
You can describe the
evolution of the wave
function as a function of time
by using this wave equation.
And this wave equation is
slightly different from what
we have learned before.
And we also can use what
we have learned from 8.03
to solve a particle in a box
problem, which is covered
in lecture number 23.
And I just wanted
to say that you
need to know the
general principle,
but I'm not teaching
8.04, so I'm not
expecting you to solve a
quantum mechanics problem.
But I would like to say
that OK, from this point,
it's motivating you
to take 8.04, right?
Because there can be a
lot of fun there as well.
And it is closely related to
what we have learned from 8.03.
So I just want to
say, the last point
is that this is really not
the end of the vibrations
and waves.
It's just the beginning.
And that there is a
path toward the peak.
And it may take a long
time to reach the peak.
All right.
And I would like to let you
know that I'm really, really
very happy to be your
lecturer this semester.
And I really enjoyed
teaching this class
and getting your responses
when I asked questions.
Thank you for the support.
And I would like to say good
luck with the final exam.
And we have 800 contributions
on Piazza, many thanks to Yinan,
who is actually doing all
the hard work, day and night.
And thank you very much, and see
you around MIT in the future.
Thank you.